let's talk about Isis for a second not
only goes by those crazy kids don't do
something this is actually about the
staggering amount of support that
apparently they have out of the Arab
world al Jazeera did a poll on their
website and the results are pretty
bonkers let's take a look okay so the
question that al Jazeera posed on the
site was do you support the organizing
victories of the Islamic state in Iraq
and Syria eighty-one percent of the
people that responded said yes and
nineteen percent said no all right
here's a little more information on al
Jazeera al Jazeera's Arabic television
audience is largely made up of Sunni
Muslims living in the Arab world its
biggest viewership numbers come from
Egypt and Saudi Arabia along with a
large amount of satellite television
viewers in the United States al Jazeera
debt is most popular in Saudi Arabia the
United States Egypt Morocco and
bosnia-herzegovina al Jazeera claims
that it has over 40 million viewers in
the Arab world ok so first off while
that seems incredibly shocking and
depressing and scary you have to take
polls like this with a grain of salt of
course because this is people that are
self reporting that are going to al
Jazeera's site so it's a very small
select sample of the types of people
that are going there and people I think
often when they respond to polls somehow
for whatever reason come out more
extreme than they may be actually are so
that being said though this is
incredibly scary no matter what so let's
shave off 20 points off this Paul and
let's say it's about sixty percent
that's still an awful lot of people who
are sympathizing with this movement now
of course all the time we talked about
and I talked about that the US and the
West we've done terrible things and we
bomb people and nobody gets bombed and
then goes I like the guy who Bobby it's
just not how it works I think a lot of
times we try to do good and then it goes
bad I think a lot of this you know you
could put blame everyone blames even now
I still see this on Twitter everyone
constantly blamed George W Bush for
everything because we went into the
wrong war in Iraq and that there is no
doubt about that I'd say about half now
is on bush and probably half is on Obama
because we screwed up Iraq without
question and
that's on George Bush for sure and then
what's on Obama is we left as he
promised to do and nobody wanted to be
there anymore right nobody wants to be
in this war even though right now
actually we're bombing Syria with no
congressional authorization Obama's
doing that right now just like he bombed
Libya with no congressional
authorization another topic I know but I
think you have to put fifty percent on
the of the blame on Obama because Isis
is getting stronger there is no doubt
about it Iraq basically in Syria are no
longer countries in any way that we view
functioning States so what Isis wants
this Islamic caliphate is happening
maybe it's supposed to happen if they're
part of the world maybe maybe whatever
but I think we have to have a bit of a
more mature discussion about this then
certainly we're having in the news and
I'm curious to know what you guys think
what our role is in the United States
because we of course helped create this
mess but what's the role of Europe
what's the role of all these other
countries that are right there Saudi
Arabia Egypt Turkey that are on the
borders of these countries what's their
role in in fixing this or you know it
seems like if we don't do anything then
nobody does anything right and then they
hate us when we do do something so it's
a it's a damned the damn strange
situation anyway let me know your
thoughts in the comments right now